one year into the pandemic and it's been
marked by many milestones for one family
it's a year
they almost didn't have together denise
brings us their story in today's health
watch denise
well christian a southern california
mother and her baby are finally home
today after they both nearly died from
coped 19.
just as they were starting their life
together they faced their biggest battle
i'm ecstatic we've been waiting for this
moment
for quite some time now that is yvette
camacho smiling no doubt under that mask
as she wheeled her newborn daughter
emery out of the hospital
now yvette has been battling covid since
january
at just 30 years old she had no
pre-existing conditions other than her
pregnancy
she was so sick she had to be airlifted
to cedar sinai medical center and put on
life support
her baby needed to be delivered right
away at just 26 weeks
if she had not come to us or even if we
delayed
the the transfer for whatever reason i
don't think that
unfortunately either her or baby would
have would have survived this
well she woke up a week later wasn't
even aware of the delivery her only
contact with her little newborn was over
face
time one month and just two pounds later
emery was strong enough to leave the
hospital today
doctors are still searching though why
some pregnant women with no pre-existing
conditions can get so
sick with covid so it is recommended
that pregnant women
talk to their doctors about whether they
should get the coping vaccine